what do you call a sleeping bull a
bulldozer imagine you wake up from your
sleep one night to find that someone is
trying to harm you you try moving your
hands and legs but you cannot move a
single muscle in your body even your
voice seems choked you feel helpless did
you know that such situations are really
experienced by people why does this
happen let's find out there is a
scientific reason behind this this could
be due to a sleep disorder called sleep
paralysis this strange phenomenon can
occur at two different moments while
sleeping one is when we're just falling
asleep and second during one of the
stages of our sleep cycle called the
rapid eye movement let's talk about the
second case which is more serious than
the first we know that we go through two
major stages during a sleep cycle one is
the non rapid eye movement sleep
which itself is subdivided into four
stages and the second is the rapid eye
movement sleep and REM sleep in general
is a dreamless sleep and these stages
are the ones which lead into the rapid
eye movement or REM now during REM sleep
the brain is very active it isn't this
stage that we have vivid dreams another
characteristic of the stage is that the
muscles of the body are essentially
turned off this is done by our brain to
avoid hurting ourselves or others during
dreams now what if a person suddenly
wakes up before the completion of the
REM stage sometimes in such a case the
mind is alert with eyes wide open but
the muscles don't function that is the
body cannot move even as dreams continue
to play inside the head
hence the person experiences auditory
and sensory hallucinations scary right
it is believed that for intent people
experience this condition at least once
in the lifetime but for some
unfortunately it occurs frequently well
in how you might remember this video if
you ever have sleep paralysis
we saw how sleeper Alice's can occur
while we are in REM sleep during the
stage our brain shuts down the muscle
movements while we're dreaming but now
consider this interesting possibility
what if the opposite happens that is we
are in the REM sleep we are dreaming but
our brain fails to shut down our muscle
movement what will happen in such a case
is such a condition even possible well
this is your cue box to explore let us
know your findings in the comment
section to join the massive community of
learners please subscribe to our Channel
and to master life never stop being
curious
[Music]